we are going to
take some calls we are going to take
calls via discord as we often do you can
find the discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's talk to some people starting here
with alex from baltimore alex you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
all right
first i want to say i do thank my lucky
stars every day that i've knocked david
packard thank you kidding of course
that's a predator right there
yes yes you are kidding again okay so
uh one of the better faith arguments i
hear from your average joe and jane
against progressive policies would be
not ideological so much as
the american government and the
bureaucracy within it's just though
bloated slow
wasteful expensive
that we don't even want to take the
chance to give them a bigger a bigger uh
program more responsibility because
they're just gonna screw it up and cost
us a ridiculous amount of money and it's
gonna be terrible um as a someone who
wants those policies implemented
is there
truth to that and how would you approach
dealing with that if it is true so i
think it's hard to deal in generalities
it's a very popular talking point just
to say the government's incompetent
don't give the government more stuff to
do the very very sounds very tight neat
and tidy as a talking point the reality
is that many of the proposals from the
left would actually simplify the
bureaucratic aspect of it for example
there are proposals as some say
to eliminate a whole bunch of small
means-tested social welfare programs and
put in place one program with either
only one bureaucracy for means testing
or no means testing at all that's a
dramatic simplification and you're
actually making it more likely that
government will succeed because it's a
much simpler program so number one a lot
of times you're not really giving
government more stuff to do
and then number two in terms of the
bloat argument many of the people
advocating for government to start doing
certain things are also saying
government should stop doing certain
things so whereas they want to grow one
area they're saying shrink another and
so th that argument sounds appealing but
it's quite literally untrue in many
cases
yeah no i i get that and i'm that's just
more of
me debating with people but i cert
sometimes i do kind of agree with them
in certain things a good example
like infrastructure and high-speed rail
in particular you hear stories that oh
they shut it down in california because
it was costing 25 million dollars a mile
meanwhile france who is
quite progressive for the most part and
has lots of unions can do it for nine
million dollars a mile yeah and i mean
what you've got to remember is in
general europe is much better at trains
than the united states so when you're
better at something you're usually going
to do it more cheaply and number two the
government isn't building the rail
they're hiring people to do it so at the
end of the day it's actually private
industry that needs to get better so
listen it's very loud where you are so
i'm going to let you go i'm curious what
are you doing are you running a lathe or
something
uh no i i work at a weld shop i'm a pipe
fitter okay you're fitting pipe during
the call
oh well no i stepped outside it was a
little breezy i tried to get away from
it oh i see the pipe fitting would have
been even louder
well yeah there's lots of welding even
more motors and then clanking and pipe
wrenches so it would have been worse all
right i appreciate it i appreciate it
thank you for the call thanks david take
care yep alex stepped out of the pipe
fitting area very very important a great
way to support the david pakman show is
by supporting our sponsors today one of
our sponsors is sheath underwear the
only men's underwear that once and for
all ends the sticking
and the chafing and the readjusting that
traditional underwear causes sheath
creates ergonomic boxer briefs designed
to keep everything separate dry cool and
comfortable if you've only worn
traditional underwear give sheath a try
it's a level of comfort you probably
didn't even know is possible because it
prevents skin on skin contact this is
the future of underwear stop wearing
uncomfortable underwear that mashes and
constricts
wear sheath to keep yourself comfortable
and sweat free the amazing reviews
online speak for themselves people love
sheath underwear it's excellent and
sheath is giving my audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below